the only thing that gave me enough balls
to stand up to my dad to be fair from a
distance from the car when I was driving
halfway across the country was the idea
that like I started thinking like every
day I was like I hope I don't wake up
you know what I mean that was the thing
where I was like this is a big enough
problem that like if you don't want to
wake up then what have you got to lose
exactly I have nothing to lose if
everybody who's like at the bottom and
feels like they have nothing going for
them reframe that as I have nothing
going for me which also means that I
have nothing to lose by taking action it
makes you a much more dangerous person